so we saw so we saw one way of combining
2 hyperbolic polynomials in the same
direction by just multiplying them and
so that that allows us to construct
hyperbolic cones let me show you another
construction that you have seen many
many times in the previous lectures and
that's the fact that if I take a
hyperbolic polynomial in Direction e so
that's P F so if I look at P of X plus T
E or X minus T whatever and so if this
has real roots we know that if if these
are three on which we also know that
it's derivative by world Stern has also
real roots so we can we can actually
construct other hyperbolic polynomials
from on P and so for example we could
look at the the first derivative would
be to take the derivative of this with
respect to T and
[Music]
and evaluate that in T is equal to zero
and so so this is Q of X so let's call
this the P in X and so this is also
going to be hyperbolic in Direction e if
if P is hyperbolic in direction and so
we can repeat that and so we could get a
sequence P del P and so on so we could
get a sequence of polynomials with some
hyperbolic in in Direction e and because
of interlacing of the zeroes we can
actually even see that if I look at so
interlacing implies that
if I take the cone corresponding to P
that will
that will be contained in the cone
corresponding to Delpy and so on
so we have a sequence of such code so
let's let's first look at whether we can
get a nice description of objects cone
so remember the result of when agon that
I had mentioned and that was if I
express P of X plus te and I write it as
PE times T to the D plus um it was a 1 X
key to the D minus 1 plus a D minus 1 of
X T plus a D of X now if this is the
expression from P of X plus te then I
can easily get the description of del P
of X and so that's that's I take the
derivative of this with respect to T and
then I get rid of the so I get del P of
X plus te
different sheets so so in particular
what it means is that remember that I
had said that the the hyperbolic code
corresponding to P could be expressed as
the set of X in RN such that all these
polynomials a 1 of X is positive and so
on up to a G of X is e and so that means
that we get a representation as a semi
algebraic set of the derivative so these
are these are called derivative
relaxations
so we get one cone and then the big um
cone and so on and the key plus
corresponding to the derivative of P is
going to be is going to be so when I
differentiate I get all the terms of
these is a bias times a factorial of of
some term but I will get that this is
simply the so a 1 X up to ad minus 1 of
X is positive and that in particular
shows obviously that it must be a subset
of and more generally KP of Delta I of P
is going to be the set of X in RN such
that you go up to 1 when you go to e
minus i effects
so for example if you take if you take
let's say the very basic hyperbolic
polynomial which is just the product of
the exercise the first one is actually
the positive Alton's and that can be
expressed as all the elementary
symmetric functions being positive and
then as you take these derivative
relaxations you get bigger and bigger
cones and you only look at some of the
elementary symmetric functions being
constrained to be to be positive now so
one thing that Reina can also observe is
that so when you can also observe so
from a an optimization point of view
that's interesting is that if you can if
can evaluate it can evaluate P
efficiently
we can actually then can evaluate also
any any of these relaxations efficiently
so you can evaluate the I derivative of
P efficiently as well and this is this
is easy to do it simply comes from the
fact that you'd like to evaluate when so
so the the for example del P of X is
going to correspond to ad minus one
effects so you'd like to evaluate a the
coefficients you'd like to find the
coefficients of of these polynomial and
because all all these when you evaluate
in T is equal to 0 will correspond to
one of these terms times appropriate
constant and so to but to compute these
terms you can just evaluate this
polynomial and from several values of T
and then and then just do interpolation
so you can use discrete fast fast for
you I mean fast discrete Fourier
transform to get these
everything will go away for the ad minus
1
right but when you it's true that so so
so it's true that del P of X is indeed a
it's going to be ad minus 1 of X times x
PE so it's going to be so if you like P
of X P of X is just P of e times ad of X
del P of X is going to be P of e times a
D minus 1 of X but when you when you
apply this operation one more time you
have to add te and you will get
we get only so-so because you can
evaluate jeez again using using internal
point algorithms using the these theory
of self component functions that was
established by Nesterov and Emile Heskey
you can actually not just optimize
efficiently from hyperbolic cones that
correspond to a P that you can evaluate
but also these derivative relaxations as
well so so for example if you take if
you take let's say the if you take let's
say semi definite programming semi
definite programming so if you take the
cone of of positive semi definite
matrices so that says that all the
elementary symmetric functions of the
eigenvalues should be it's in a negative
positive if you take the positive
definite code but then you can actually
if you look at only the for most D - I
you can still optimize over from the set
of symmetric matrices such that G is d
minus 1 D - I elementary symmetric
function of the eigenvalues are positive
so that's something that was I mean when
people were looking at semi definite
programming that was not completely
obvious how one could do that so
like this if you just take the
derivative then you and it set to zero
only left with a t minus one how do you
recover the a 1 X greater than 0 in your
I guess now there are two questions
maybe I should look at it more carefully
if you okay so one second you take
I mean you relative X plus GE you are
getting honest
the evaluative eggs
I think you get the a one act when you
then to get K del P you need to forget
the roots of the polynomial del V along
X plus T oh so you again get a part
number th810 fish right so I think that
[Music]
[Music]
you could yeah and then stead T's good
thank you
so
[Applause]
other applications of this so this is
this is a very good question so so it's
it's buttes mean in my opinion it's a
beautiful it's a beautiful frame wonk
welcome there is not I mean in terms of
the optimization point of view I don't
think there is the a great application
of it the I mean so for example if you
look at if you look at let's say
semi-definite programming one thing that
I find interesting is that for example
if you look at the stable set polytope
of of a perfect graph so that's that's a
polytope that has an exponential number
of facets you can optimize over it
efficiently you can separate over it
efficiently but the way you do that is
by formulating it as a semi definite
program and then optimizing over that
theta body of lo vas so that's the
results of Rocha love as inscribing so
even though you you have a polyhedron
set that's reasonably well understood
one doesn't know how to use the
techniques of linear programming to
optimize avoid and one needs to go to
semi definite programming it seems that
the same story could could happen here
in some place and it's up to one of you
to discover means is to that then could
be the they could be so for example I
mean what I'm really wondering about
these matching this matching pollito
because in we can optimize over matching
sufficiently in polynomial time we can
if we look at the matching polytope we
can separate so if I give you a point I
can find a in equality that's violated
in polynomial time improved at that
point is inside the polytope and i can
do all kinds of things but
there is no I I need to use for example
the ellipsoid algorithm to be able to
optimize off on that poly tope on the
width community lipid but would be need
if I could show that it's it can be
viewed as the hyperbolic oh I mean as a
section of a knife Ambala cone and be
able to I mean so for example the
awesome I come by I haven't discussed
that but on some hyperbolic polynomials
that arise from fashion and so so that
might be a way that possibly one might
be able to get to two matchings but i
really don't know so so I think I I
think it's an interesting question so so
even even if so from so for example if
let's say that that the that the
generalized lacks conjecture
let's say is true so suppose it's true
exactly if you have to go very high it
isn't so in terms of optimization it
doesn't mean that much and so there
might be some I mean even though it's it
would show that it's not more powerful
than semi definite programming in terms
of representation but it could still
mean that one could do it much more
efficiently by looking at these
hyperbolic thing they're like randomized
version of randomized surrounding just
in carbolic city series wonderful linear
program
know that I yeah now that I know of so
so any autumn question I mean I wish
there would be the answer was yes so
that's that's my that's my hope and I
one of you should be able to to do it
that's one comments that there are so if
you have some papers which we don't use
hyperbolic groups no code but the use
hyperbolic Colombians like elementary
symmetric polynomials for optimization
because they are that means they're
talking cavity of these problems so
let's AMA for National Park you will
hear hear about it sometimes with this
program but so I'm saying okay so you
can't yeah you can these are this gives
you lock on [ __ ] [ __ ] K polynomial
you can do optimization over it and then
you can use it that we have used but
yeah I agree we haven't used the cone at
the fines but this polynomial
okay so let me I mentioned initially
that I was going to talk a bit about the
connection between hyperbola city and so
hyperbolic polynomials and stable
polynomials so let me state a few state
one one basic resume very simple so if I
so remember the notion of stability if I
take a polynomial let's say over the
complex we say that it's it's stable if
if I have if let's say X is in
H to the N one H is the set of X in C
such that the imaginary part of X is
positive that if I have an X which is in
the upper half plane then that P of X is
non zero so I guess you probably have
seen mostly we don't stable polynomials
so these are with real coefficients
that's the notion generally and so one
can show the following many of the
hyperbolic polynomials that we have been
discussing actually hyperbolic from the
entire non-negative autant and so if you
have a polynomial P
so if you have a real polynomial and
it's a mo genius
then so then it's going to be William
stable or save them if and only if P is
hyperbolic all all non-negative or e so
that's a and and this is very so that
should be a two minute exercise you can
easily show that if P stable then take
any non-negative direction it's going to
be hyperbolic and vice versa so that's
that's one one relationship between the
notion of stability and and I properly
city I should I should emphasize that I
mean it's very simple trick is that when
it's am a genius
which have space you can sit on doesn't
matter because you can always so for
example I could have defined this to be
as the half space corresponding to the
real point being positive for example
because you can always multiply and and
not not change
so good let me let me maybe so let me go
back to convexity because of the
hyperbolic polynomial because I think
this was this is a very important result
and let me we I didn't so I claim that
if if you have a hyperbolic polynomial
in Direction E and then you take a point
in that hyperbolic cone that the
polynomial will also be hyperbolic in
that direction
so let me let me prove that and I'm
going to I mean this was proved by
Counting
a long time ago but let me use the
exposition of patent London in one of
these in one of these surveys so let me
show the following that let me take let
me take a
[Music]
let me take a polynomial that key
the a machine is polynomial and and to
two victims which routes and now let me
first assume that p is hyperbolic that's
it
a wheel of comes on P is hyperbolic in
Direction e and let's assume that and F
belongs to
- yeah - Bala : and so I'd like to show
that this is equivalent to saying that
if I look at a be valued polynomial in s
NT which maps to X plus and this should
be for every X so if I look at the
bhavani polynomial which maps to P of X
plus s ii + t f that this is this is a
stable polynomial for every every X and
so out of this so one thing that's
pretty obvious since this is symmetric
in any n a in en F is that so
so we showed that the the two iquivalent
so that these two statements I couldn't
so once we show this as a basic
corollary it means that since this is
symmetric in en f it shows that if P is
hyperbolic in Direction e and I take a
point which is in the hyperbolic cone
then it will mean that it's also I /
Baalak in that other direction and he
belongs to that the corresponding icon
Baalak so I should say
that means as a corollary we would
address of e is equal to K so P is
hyperbolic
[Music]
in every
never
[Music]
yes
so let me prove that lemma because
that's really the onion has on
blackboard
[Music]
so
we from a show that
[Music]
ooh in plies one I need to show that I'm
assuming that this behind polynomial is
stable for every X and I need to show
that it's hyperbolic in Direction e so I
need to look at P of X so I need to show
that it's hyperbolic in Direction e in
that it belongs to K plus so
so I'm going to look at this polynomial
and so the first thing I'm going to do
is that I'm going to so I know it's
stable but I'm going to take a tea
that's that's in the open up on complex
plane so I take let's say T to be T to
be let's see epsilon I 1 epsilon is
positive times T and so if I look at so
epsilon I times F so if I look at if I
look at the words mooching since Jesus
positive imaginary point I know that
the fact that it's stable means that a
root will have non non positive and so
so this is going to be so this is stable
this is stableman in s and since the by
continuity of the words this is also
true if epsilon tends to 0 so that means
that this polynomial P of X plus s e as
a polynomial as a univariate polynomial
in s is also stable for every Y reacts
so so that means that this is a
univariate polynomial X and so a 1/8 of
so
so E and X I know n and so that means
that since its stable it means that the
words must be cannot be in the upon half
plane but since it's a we on polynomials
they will come in conjugate things and
so that means that the roots as our
wheel so that's precisely the notion of
hyperbolic the from spunk
the second part is slightly longer so if
I take so now I am assuming that I have
a hyperbolic polynomial in Direction E
and that F belongs did I show no no I'm
not done yet
I was I was just noticing that yes I'm
not done I have to also prove that F
belongs to belongs to it so
and so it belongs to it so now I'm going
to look at
so
if I look at
[Applause]
I'm going to write it down on my notes
so I'll have to rediscover it someone
who wrote the original yeah so if I set
X to zero so and I look at P of s e + EF
now so I need to look at so ein the
product over the eigenvalues can you
just set one of the variables to one and
then if it's stable that it's unitary
that's really urgent yeah but you need
to be possible
[Music]
so if I said these t21 so now I get that
this is the product so
what do you say s is equal to s +
and I of F yeah so as of lambda I of F
yes and then and so the so what I need
to show is I I lost what I need is I
need to show that the is that s right
then it's done
so he's not the same as to argue that we
indeed take epsilon greater than zero
but positive right then routes a scan on
G get it lined up our health plane and
therefore if you take epsilon goes to 0
they cannot jump into the yeah
that was amazing sighs I was in the
exact size for me not for you okay I
think I got that I mean you got that but
I think so
does everyone agree
yeah okay so
they're using the lambda of TF is T
times whether ya lambdai yes right
exactly yeah do it so that's that's the
foremost nice one from the second one so
if P is the PSI from Pollock in
Direction e and then I look at so I want
to show that so so let me first so I
want to show that this is stable so um
phone's going to fix fix and s let's
call it a zero in the upper half plane
and so now if I look at I look at the
the roots of the polynomial that map's T
2 P of X plus a 0 e plus GF I need to
show that this is stable so let me first
look at the case in which so first let's
look at X is equal to 0
so when X is equal to zero I have the
polynomial is polynomial and and so I
know that I know that so this polynomial
is going to be so let me move you Thomas
0t since I have so let me move T so this
is T to the D times the polynomial a 0
divided by T E Plus F now so this is a
polynomial of F plus something times e
and so I know that since its hyperbolic
in Direction e so this better be we
young and also it better be
so as 0 so if if I have route a fruit if
I have a route this better be a 0 t
minus 1 should better be we on and also
it better be they don't be negative so
and negative and so since a 0 has is in
the upon half plane that means that T is
such that it's imaginary pound
since the imaginary part since the
imaginary part of a zero is is positive
then the imaginary part of T is going to
be negative and so that means that
indeed indeed this polynomial in the
case of X is equal to zero is indeed
stable so that that shows that that that
gives the case from X is equal to zero
so the polynomial this polynomial is
stable now when X so suppose that
suppose that there is an X such that
this is not true then it's not stable so
what we'll simply do is we'll simply go
from X is equal to 0 to so assume assume
that an X such that
from st to PF x + SE f st f that this is
not not stable so let me take so if i
look at
so that means that actually let me look
at let me fix as zero so let me look at
so let me let me show that this
polynomial is stable so let me look at
this so see if this is not stable what
it means is that I have a routing such
that T is is in the is not in H so if T
is not in age but T was an age when I
was looking at roots of X is equal to
zero it means that between X and that X
is X hat and X hat that along the way
between X X is equal to 0 and X hat I
have a route that goes from by
continuity of the roots again by
continuity of the roots I have a word
that goes from imaginary part less than
0 to imaginary part bigger than 0 and so
there must be a value from which the
polynomial which is P of a multiple of X
plus s 0 e plus so I would have a root
which as we own so in which T is we own
and that's a root but that's a
contradiction because that's a
contradiction because this is this is we
own and that is we own and and so I have
if I look at the definition of if I look
at the definition of I properly city
in direction II it means that from that
point if I look in the direction
II the route should be should be real
while a zero is not is not real so that
shows again that this is stable and
since that was for every a zero that
means that the polynomial so that was a
bit of a slow exercise for me
but it's getting late so the so one
other thing that I I wanted to mention
but I think I already so was in terms of
so we already kind of mentioned it but
we so when we looked at regular matrix
and and also and these spanning-tree
polynomials we looked at the multi
lynnium case multi linear case with
actually even coefficients which were so
we looked at for example some of them
being B X B so I'm looking at
coefficients which are which are units I
in B and so we saw that for example if
we take the if we take the basis of a
regular Metroid that this is hyperbolic
in in actually any direction in the
positive moment and so so one question
that one could want on is from which B
which B is on which B is these P effects
hyperbolic
in in in direction so Susie since this
is a polynomial with positive with
non-negative coefficients we could for
example from if I come Baalak in in
direction so so one thing that was that
was proved by show Oxley
obviously circle and Wagner a no phone
is that actually that that FP is if P is
the pure FX is hyperbolic then actually
and let's assume that actually wine the
homogeneous case so let's assume that B
is actually a subset of let's say n
choose D so if P is Aipom Baalak then B
must be must be the basis of a Metroid
and and so so so the various ways of of
showing this but but unfortunately the
the conference is not true so this is
not true and so may trade which which
come from which pfx is hyperbolic could
be called hyperbolic matrix on the they
often are called I mean at least in that
paper they call it which is upon half
plain property so these are the half
plain poverty
[Music]
and so what so let's say all one's Oh
actually since you can take I mean so if
you look at the if if you look at the
code it's going to consider it's going
to contain at least all the the internal
positive fountain so you could use
anything in the positive moment and so
the but the converse is not true and so
for example there are quite a few of
these that are not quite a few matrix
that are not hyperbolic so so the we
know that the regular matrix we know
that the regular that property let's see
so we know that the regular ones and
hyperbolic we know that one can show
that all the uniform one's hyperbolic
one can also show quite a few which are
not so one can show that the fan oh so
the fan Oh metroid is not and also
hyperbolic is closed until taking dual
Metroid's taking doing so that it means
that the fan oh but also the strong is
not the also I mean the non fan oh that
PAP is there are quite a few that are
not non purpose and so on so when you
see a result like this the puppies are
not so this is a publicity does not
characterize matrix and so I guess there
will be probably Nima might be talking
about the right
so I prompt olicity is not the right
characterization for matrix and Nima in
joint wrong with cheyenne and another
ones will show we show the right
property from characterizing arbitrator
I don't want to talk too much about
about this any questions
[Music]
yes that's the that's the same yes yeah
that's the same because that's that's
going to be I mean the so you know I put
coefficients of one you can also look at
you can you can put other coefficients
but but so if you have Adam so if you
look at polynomials with our own
coefficients then you look at the
super-mo so so you want to look at the
support of the so the monomials which
are nonzero and then so so that's going
to be the same as the exactly right
that's what I so stability and iPhone
Baalak in all non-negative directions of
the same yeah I mean but yeah so I mean
because what once it's it's hyperbolic
in one direction the entire positive
intent will be in the cone and so it's
going to be hyperbolic in all directions
in independent in the positive Alton e 1
e 2 and some EK from the truncated than
the Express
I guess so but he seems to say yes so
yes good let's take a little break I
actually don't have too much left I
should say that so for example I mean
maybe before taking a break and maybe we
can finish only is that among these so
so I said if if you have a if you have a
that you what what could happen is that
so even though so from if I take for
example so so if I look at the cone
corresponding to such a P so there might
be many peas that will present the same
cone so for example if I take just a
power of P of X if I take a power of P
of X then that would represent so the
zeros will be the same and so the cone
will be and so one question is that if
you take a hyperbolic polynomial so if
so I mentioned whether it has a spectral
even representation but so one you could
ask I mean not just if if if P as a if P
corresponds to one of these determinants
on representation so the determinant of
some of X I a I but you could also look
at for example a power of P of X and so
one of the result that pattern brandon's
as shown is that that there exist matrix
so the the varmus matrix from which the
for no power of P you can represent it
you have a spectral representation that
doesn't mean though that I mean you
might have you might have different I
mean you you you can x autumn
polynomials and get a is betrayed
so let's let's stop now I'm getting a
bit tired and I'm shown that you're not
getting tired as well so do I have any
small open questions to ask you I mean
let me let me just emphasize again that
I mean one thing that I I I mean the
reason so I'm not exactly I'm still not
sure why they invited me to give these
lectures and that's the bottom line
the but essentially I think they I think
they invited me because I feel that
these hyperbolic optimization is I mean
that this hyperbolic polynomials and
cones is a beautiful mathematical
terrine and I and and there is ease
these class of convex optimization
problems for which you get efficient
solvability provided you can you can
compute these polynomials essentially
for free and so that's extremely
powerful and so the the the I mean one
thing I'd love to do is to be able to
find as a shebang we're not asked so a
nice application of it maybe from
discrete optimization on from from some
other class of problem so so that's my
some key tomorrow in the talks in the
morning you'll hear more about these
determinants on representation so these
these questions about spectra Edra and
but but one thing I would love for you
to do is to find and a killing
for example discrete optimization
problem from which from which hyperbolic
programming optimization is the
so maybe let's that's my big open
question and not stop you I mean I think
you should ask Cheyenne or NEMA so NEMA
for example when he gives the talks on
Friday on to my way I don't know exactly
when he talks but they that might be no
he's not no you can define like some
cone for like a polynomial as well so
yeah I guess one comment is a disease
sheriff this lot speed barrier function
the self course probably the best and
those are exactly the properties that
are used in the yeah I mean it's reduced
the improving mathematical theorems but
has not actually been used as a
so just one comment to give one thing
I've been I've been trying for example
to use elementary symmetric polynomial
on the cone of it and but why do you
find hard is a it's even not easy to
describe the whole thing okay it's like
the victory sighs Daniel Pablo and again
I'm delegating to the audience
well thanks
[Applause]